one thing that uh came up in these
stories today that i really thought was
interesting and i'd love to get your
take on everybody is we're gonna talk
about spoilers
um now i just assumed everyone hates a
spoiler uh it turns out some people love
them the washington post reports that
some people want to know how a tv show
ends before they watch it or they like
to read that last page of the book
before they buy it very when harry met
sally they say spoilers help them
determine if they want to invest the
time in a tv show movie book and for
some knowing the outcome helps them
enjoy the ride even more ross thoughts
well you know i don't like to judge
anybody
something is seriously wrong with you
i don't i don't like you i don't know
you i don't want to know you what why
why would you want to know how it ends
why would you want to know that carrie
ended up with big sorry if you didn't
know why would you
why would you want to know that and not
go on the journey of the character you
need help i'm sorry but you do
okay show of hands who
likes spoilers in the audience
now listen i i'm i
you look so normal to me sitting there
i i see a woman right here in the front
row um what is your name
and why did you raise your hand
uh my name is karina and when i go to
the bookstore and pick up a book i
always go to the ending if i don't like
the ending i don't buy the book now
listen you seem normal to me right i do
but don't you uh don't you want to go on
the journey dear don't you want to you
know find out and see what happens yeah
but the spoiler ending of the book tells
me whether or not the journey
is going to be worth reading the the
rest of the book
you know
[Laughter]
like tv series like if i find out a
series is being cancelled that i'm
watching i'm just like i just drop it
[Laughter]
i'm sorry to disappoint well you'll be
happy to know yellowstone just got
picked up
[Applause]
thank you for participating thank you i
still don't get you but thank you
i love that we can
learn from each other
all right next up uh do you want to know
what the end of the story is before i
get to it all right
next up now i kind of want to try it
okay scroll to the last line i'll give
you the last line
i can do it
here or the last line instead why not
give the bride a hand
[Laughter]
[Applause]
back to the top and try this we're
talking about the wedding term that some
experts say we have to retire anyone
ever heard of the term bridezilla
uh-huh well insider reports that term
was coined way back in the 90s and it's
been thrown about so much but it is
actually unfair because they say
planning a wedding really is stressful
it is emotional and we don't need to
demonize women who are just trying to
pull together a big day under a ton of
pressure instead they say
why not give that bride a hand
why not give the bride a hand i'll tell
you i'm in the middle of planning a
wedding right now and i am not
groomzilla okay i was maybe in a moment
or two in the not even the neighborhood
of groomzilla but the area code okay
like a moment of stress
and um
just yesterday they did a facetime like
at the venue of what it's going to be
and something in my head clicked and it
was all gone you know all the stress was
gone really yeah and i think there
should be that moment i hope there's
that moment for every bride every groom
out there every person who's having a
wedding where you do get to let go to
that because it is so stressful and to
demonize people who are just trying to
have a moment is wrong
i this one made me feel bad about the
term i was like yeah you're right like
if you're really going through it and
you got a ton of pressure and all that
stuff the last thing you need is someone
giving you a rude nickname that's going
to make you feel worse about yourself
yeah how about we just don't judge
people who are just trying to express
love how about that
right
we could do that
i like how everybody likes to do it and
they should be supported and not be
called some ratty little name for it
we'll be right back
[Music]